un personnage qui se pose aujourd'hui en
oppositionnel entre guillemets mais qui
est le pur produit en fait du type
d'économie capitaliste qui s'est
développée en chine parce que jack ma
c'est à développer ses activités sous le
parapluie du parti on sait très bien
qu'on ne peut pas développer des grandes
entreprises
même privé entre guillemets sans
l'accord du parti sans le soutien
maximum du du parti mais aujourd'hui
gouvernement chinois et le parti sont
confrontés à une difficulté c'est à dire
que d'un côté il y a une certaine
autonomisation des milieux d'affaires
parce qu'aujourd'hui quelqu'un comme
jack ma est beaucoup plus proche
finalement du grand d'un god un patron
comme le patron de total par un patron
d'un d'une grande multinationale
étrangère
sur le plan des pratiques sur le plan
des mentalités et c'est que évidemment
des dirigeants du parti
donc la grande question aujourd'hui qui
se pose c'est la croissance économique
et la croë est précisément ce projet
d'impérialisme je dirais une projection
à l'extérieur est-ce qu'il doit être
fait au profit de la nation et du parti
ou au profit d'une nouvelle caste on
pourrait dire de businessmen plus ou
moins évidemment à des indépendants du
gouvernement ce qui se passe évidemment
aux états unis ou en europe on sait bien
que les grands patrons ne sont pas
indépendants des gouvernements
évidemment qui les soutiennent mais il y
a une marge de manoeuvre il ya une marge
d'autonomie
la question c'est effectivement
aujourd'hui entre les milieux d'affaires
éliminé deux parties n'ont pas d'un côté
des méchants du parti de l'autre côté
les gentils du business mais la marge je
dirais d'autonomisation des milieux du
business
chinois par rapport au parti
[Musique]